Transcriber: 19 Shaffiee
المدقّق: Mujtaba Abdelwhab
وسوون .
السلام عليكم ورحمة الله وبركاته .
طيب .
كثير من الشباب اليوم يطمحون بالنصر عندهم
شركتهم وصار عندهم المال والقوة ، وكل هذا
الشيء جميل في مخيلتهم الصغيرة ، ولكن في
الجهة الأخرى عشان الشاب الطموح هذا ينجح
لازم مقابل إحدى عشر شخص يفشل .
أي بما يعني أكثر من تسعين بالمئة من رواد
الأعمال اليوم يفشلون النسبه كان جدا كبير
صادما بالنسبة لي ، فبدأت أبحث أكثر الأسباب
التي تجعل رواد العمل يفشلون .
وجدت أن في بعضها أمور تقنية
أمور لها علاقة بالتسويق .
وهناك سبب وهو لربما يكون أكبر .
إن عدم احتياج للفكرة من أساسها .
ولكن هناك سبب صغير أو بسيط دائما
ما يتم تجاهل بشكل أو بآخر .
هل الشخص هذا مؤهل بالنصر رائد أعمال
أو هل هو لديه العقلية الريادية ؟
نحن للأسف توربينا بشكل خاطئ من الصدر ،
وأنا ما قلت بانه شيء خطر لا أقصد للآباء
الآباء والأمهات ، ولكن تم وضعنا في نظام في
المدارس في الجامعات تمت معاملتنا فيه
جميعا على أننا شخص واحد ننفذ الأمور بنفس
الطريقة بإطار يرسم لنا شخص آخر ، وكل هذا
يتم تسليم في نفس التوقيت ، وهذا الشيء
يمكن قتل بعض الإبداعية والقدرة على
التفكير خارج الصندوق عند الشباب ، واليوم
المشتقات والمتغيرات جدا سريع أو كثيرة ،
فعلى سبيل المثال تطور الفكرة
بحد ذاتها أصبح جد سريع .
اليوم ممكن أنت في بيتك بجهاز لابتوب بسيط
سوا لك موقع الكتروني حساب عر السوشيال
ميديا وتبدأ تبيع منتجات العملاء إنتاجك
قابلتهم قبل كذا وتوصلا المنتج وأيضا تأخذ
ردة فعلهم عن هذا المنتج وكل
هذا فيكم أسابيع إلى أشهر .
في السابق الموضوع كان يأخذ أكثر من هذا
بكثير وهذا كان طبيعة منطقي خصوصا لضعف
التقنية وقتها وأيضا الوصول
للمعلومة اليوم جدا .
سهل سريع .
طيب هذه المشكلات أصبحت تؤثر ليس فقط على
عملنا أيضا على حياتنا الخاصة ، فسألت نفسي
من أفضل الناس تعاملنا مع هذه الأمور ،
فوجدت أن رواد الأعمال الناجح هم أفضل
الناس ، لكن قبل أن أقول لكم لماذا خدعنا
اليكم الفرق بان الشخص ذو العقلية الريادية
والشخص ذو عقلية الموظف التقليدية .
دعنا نعرف العقلية الريادية هي عبارة عن
كلمتين نمسك الكلمة الأولى ألا وهي العقلية.
ما هي العقلية ؟ هي طريقة تفكير الإنسان صح
.
ظلت العقلية هي المحرك الذي بداخلنا جميعا
الذي منه نحن نتخذ أفعالنا وتصرفاتنا بناء
عليه ، فهي مجموعة من المبادئ معتقدات
وتجارب نحن خضناها في هذه الحياة .
طيب كيف نقدر نجمع بين الشخص عندما نجمع
الكلمة هذه من حالنا ، هو شخص عنده مهارات
معينة وفنان في اقتناص الفرص ، والشخص هذا
إذا سقط أو انتكس يعرف كم مرة ثانية عشان
يحقق هدفه .
والعقلية في لها جزءين أساسيين بأثيوبيا في
عامل داخلي ، وأنت لك كامل قدرة في التحكم
التأثير فيه وفي عامل خارجي ، ولكن أيضا
عندك القدرة بالتأثير عليه باختياره للناس
الذي أنت تماشيها واختياره للتجارب التي
تخوض في هذه الحياة ، بينما في الجهة
الأخرى عقلية الموظف التقليدية يمكن المعيار
أو أحد المعايير الأساسية عنده في
اتخاذ الوظيفة .
هو سؤال كم الراتب ؟ هذا أهم سؤال بالنسبة
له قبل ما يعرف القشاشية الوظيفة ، إذا هي
الشركة ، ما القيمة التي تتطلع من وراء هذا
الشأن ؟ اسأل كم الراتب ؟ لربما تكون لديهم
أي ثانية ، ولكن هذا الأهم بالنسبة له
بالنسبة للشخص الريادي بالنسبة هو القيمة
المضافة التي يعطيها من خلال هذه الوظيفة
عشان أقدر أقدم من خلال هذه الوظيفة بحيث
أقدر أفيد المجتمع وأترك أثر .
خلونا نائبكم مثال .
لنفس الشخصين التي توظف في هذه الشركة
ولديهم مشروع وتسنيم بعد أسبوع .
الاثنين شعر بأنه بقي يعني أو سيتأخر عن
تسليم المشروع ، ويجيء هذا الشخص ذو عقلية
الموظف التقليدية يستغل باقي الفترة نيش بأن
يفكر في أسباب وأعذار عشان يقول المدير .
عندما نأتي وقت التسليم الشخص الريادي رح
يوقف الخطة هو اشعلها وغيرها تماما يتكيف
مع خطة جديدة عشان يقدر يسلمها في موعدها ،
وممكن يروح المدير ويقول له تعال ساعدني .
أنا أحتاج في هذا المشروع في
وقته وليس فيها أي خطأ .
اليوم .
يمكن في خدعنا نقل رواد الأعمال حياتهم بشكل
كبير قائمة على الضبابية وعدم الوضوح
، على عكس الشركات الكبيرة يمكن لك خطة
لمدة سنة سنتين عشر سنين يمكن أن تصل
لخمسين سنة .
رائد الأعمال المسكين يمكن أسبوع جيماريش
أن يسر له ممكن يقفل بزنس حقه من أساسه
لأنه لا يعرف من العمل الذي يقابلهم ، كم
ستدخل فلوس كل هذا بالنسبة له مجهولة .
من ينجح فيهم الذي يعرف يتكيف مع الوضع الذي
هو فيه ويستغل الفرص في الوقت الصحيح
وكل هذا بانضباط كبير .
اليوم يمكن في مجتمعات تتكلم بلسان ريادة
الأعمال ، وأشخاص يتكلمون بلسان ريادة
الأعمال ، وهذا حق لهم ، ولكن الفكر بحد
ذاته ليس حكرا عليهم ، فاليوم نحن لدينا
أمثلة من أشخاص الرياديين في مجالات مختلفة
دون أن يكون عندهم مشاريع ريادية ، فعلى
سبيل المثال لو سألتك الآن من في مدرس أو
دكتور مهما مطالبي الزمن مستحيل تنسى سيخطف
بالك كم شخص ؟ لماذا ؟ لأنه كان مختلف
تماما في طريقة التعليم وذلك بالنسبة
للتعليم .
ما هي مهمة ايديها ؟ هذا هو الدرس .
والسلام عليكم .
بالنسبة لنا هدف .
إننا أضيف لقيمة .
فإن اختلاف في فكره في هدفه .
أيضا في كموظف تجد أشخاص في مشاريع معينة .
في أشخاص معينين هم ليتم تسليمها لهم لأنه
أنت متأكد أنه سوف ينفذه بأفضل طريقة في
الوقت المناسب .
وفي مثال أنا لا أقدر هسيب
والذي هو أساسا جميعا .
ألا وهو الأم .
الأم تعودنا دائما ان تربي ويكون عندها
مجموعة من الأطفال تربيهم تضطر تتعامل مع
مشكلة كل شخص فيهم بشكل شبه يومي وعلى مدار
السنين ، ومع ذلك تنجح بأن تبني جيل واعد .
اليوم فرصة لنا أن نبني عقلية ريادية كمجتمع
بحيث نصبح أشخاصا أفضل وأيضا موظفين
أفضل .
مرة أخرى أنا هنا رسالتي ليست بأن الجميع
يصبح رواد أعمال ويبدأ ويؤسس شركاتهم ،
ولكن بناء العقلية الريادية سوف يساعدنا
بشكل كبير بأن نصبح مجتمع أفضل بكثير .
واختتم بالآية القرآنية إن الله لا يغير
ما بقوم حتى يغيروا ما بأنفسهم .
شكرا جزيلا .